all right there there i am bit of a
false start there welcome everybody we
are live because we are expecting to
hear
from donald trump's dr sean connelly
very very soon we were told during the
3pm hour i was actually still having my
cappuccino
and i didn't want to miss this because
this is going to be
um chocolaty and velvety let's see
that's good actually i meant i didn't
want to miss the presentation
presentation here from sean connelly
doctor of osteopathic medicine because
donald trump has tweeted that he is
leaving walter reed
tweeting i will be leaving the great
walter reed medical center today at 6 30
pm
feeling really good don't be afraid of
covid don't let it dominate your life we
have developed under the trump
administration some really great drugs
and knowledge
i feel better than i did 20 years
ago so donald trump will be leaving now
here's the unfortunate reality
anything could be the truth right now
trump lies about everything including
his health
his doctor has obvious obviously
obfuscated during both his saturday and
sunday presentations
if we imagine a spectrum of what the
truth could be
where on one side it's trump never had
coronavirus and on the other side it's
trump is
dead right now and someone else is
tweeting right those would be the
extremes
i don't think those extremes are
possible i think trump does have
coronavirus
i don't think he has already died
anything else could be possible he could
have extremely mild coronavirus
or it got serious but now it's better or
it was never
serious or literally anything in between
could be possible because they have been
so so so dishonest and of course donald
trump is going to try to use this
to claim that you should vote for him we
have new polling numbers and they are
really really bad for donald trump and
that might even explain
let me see if i can pull some of those
up um
that might even explain why donald trump
is so
eager to get out of the hospital just to
give you a sense of recent polls
yesterday we got a new poll from nbc
news that has trump down
14 nationally we got a poll today
that trump is up for in ohio but this is
a known right-wing poll it's not a
high-rated poll
trump is down eight in arizona according
to a new new york times sienna poll
that's considered a good poll and that
corresponds
with the um challenger in the democratic
senate being up
11. so it could just be that trump is
panicking
the other idea and again because they're
lying we are just left to speculate
the other idea is that over the last few
days they have built up
what is effectively an icu at the white
house
the idea is to have trump trump's been
act asking to leave for days
get trump to the white house but then
know that you have the facilities there
to intubate him if you need to or or
whatever the case may be
uh i'm just gonna turn my phone down i
apologize this was thrown together so
haphazardly all right let's see what we
have for super chats as i sip my
cappuccino
wendy says trump is going to go on about
being a covet expert now of course
ken says someone who only desires power
and never shows weakness is unsuitable
for any leadership position
especially potus connor says also that
tweet by trump don't
be afraid of kovit is such a slap in the
face to the country
yeah trump is now down according to some
polls double digits among seniors
and it's believed that a lot of that is
because he
has been acting this belligerent with
regard to the virus
oh people want to hear my cappuccino sip
let me see
did the mic pick that up i think it did
this is a beautiful
microphone i think it picks things up
that i want
and not things that i don't people like
it okay very very nice
i can also do it completely silently
look
nobody knows that there's cappuccino
happening but uh anyway i did spike it
by the way with
remdesseviere and a cocktail of various
unapproved antibodies you could just
never ever ever be too too careful
um let me do a couple of clips
just from what has happened over the
last couple of days
um oh but okay let me do some thank yous
first thanks to pb and j
for the twitch sub malcolm in the little
for the twitch sub
lisa noel has subscribed uh squiggy bow
all sorts of great people big thank you
to lorraine grems who has just pledged
on patreon
some people call it patreon i think it's
funnier to call it patreon
and is lorraine is new supporter number
one today
also big thanks to leif gensert who is
supporter number two
mike zawadski is number three
seth hager is number four and marit
resnick
is number five very much appreciate the
early support
other super chats coming in chakaseki
says trump's prescription
adderall dexamethasone plasma
bleach and a dash of demon semen
administered via high pressure enema
that sounds like a full day
that sounds like a very full day chaka
seki also commenting on kaylee maganani
testing positive chakaseki says poor
kaylee now she has one more pre-existing
condition to worry about when emperor
kobfi 19
abolishes protection for them sorry not
sorry
yes kaylee mckennany testing positive
today
and uh there one the one i'm interested
in
is william barr was in a very close
whispered conversation at the amy coney
barrett super spreader event last
saturday with kellyanne conway
and william barr initially said when
kellyanne tested positive
i'm not even going to quarantine
yesterday we learned that barr now
is going to quarantine is that code for
he tested positive and they don't want
to say
is that code for he has symptoms but he
hasn't yet tested we just don't know
because they lie all the time i have a
few
interesting little lies for you here um
where was it oh okay check this out
see if you can hear the deception if you
can figure out what the deception is in
this clip i think you'll find this clip
interesting
below 90. we'll be
uh we don't have any recordings here of
that that's right
okay did trump's oxygen saturation ever
dip below 90. sean connelly says we
don't have recordings
here of that two interpretations we
threw out the recordings or didn't make
them
or trump did have oxygen saturation
below 90 but not while at walter reed
okay it gets worse
at the white house or here anything
below 90 just to follow up on her
question
uh no it was below 94 it was it wasn't
down in the low 80s or anything
okay the question was was it below 90
and he says
it was below 94 it was not in the low
80s well that's not the question and the
reason this is relevant is that if if
trump did indeed have oxygen saturation
of 88 or 89
that is very serious coronavirus that
that is very serious
and they are just trying to hide it
it's very very transparent let me see if
i have another one
um oh here's one more
here's conley yesterday explaining why
he
lied the day before okay check this one
out
today to disclose that the president
had been administered oxygen
uh it's a good question so i was trying
to reflect the
the uh the upbeat attitude that the team
the president that his course of illness
has had
um didn't want to give any uh
any information that might uh steer the
the course of illness in another so what
does that mean
that if he had admitted trump had had
oxygen that it might have actually
affected
the course of treatment and trump would
have gotten worse the direction
um and in doing so uh you know it came
off
that we were trying to hide something
which wasn't necessarily true did you
hear that
it wasn't necessarily true that he was
trying to hide something he doesn't say
it's not true he says it's not
necessarily true all right let's take a
listen here and then we'll talk about
what's next
brace yourselves
good afternoon everyone thank you for
being here
over the past 24 hours the president has
continued to improve
he's met or exceeded all standard
hospital discharge criteria
he'll receive another dose of rem
deserve here today and then we plan to
get him home
it's been more than 72 hours since his
last fever
oxygen levels ambulatory saturations
and his work of breathing are all normal
though he may not entirely be out of the
woods yet the team and i agree that all
our evaluations
and most importantly his clinical status
support the president's safe return home
where he'll be surrounded by world-class
medical care 24 7.
i'd like to bring dr dooley up to review
some more specifics
pay attention here folks
good afternoon just a brief update this
morning as dr conley mentioned the
president uh continues to do very well
his vital signs this morning uh were
notable for a temperature of 98.1
his blood pressure was 134 over 78. a
respiratory rate of 17 respirations per
minute his heart rate was 68 minute
and his last oxyhemoglobin saturation
was 97 percent
on room air he currently uh
does not endorse any respiratory
complaints and aside from our
evaluation with the multi-disciplinary
team this morning
has maintained a full schedule
ambulating and working on the white
house medical unit
and i'll turn it over to dr garabaldi
again discuss therapeutics
thanks
hi good afternoon and again i just
wanted to echo the sentiment of what an
honor it is to to be part of this
this wonderful team here at walter reed
uh yesterday evening the president
received his third dose of remdessevier
he tolerated that infusion without
difficulty and his kidney and liver
function continued to be normal our plan
is to give the fourth dose of
rem deciver this evening before he goes
back to the white house and we've made
arrangements to deliver the fifth and
final dose of his treatment course at
the white house tomorrow
he continues on dexamethasone and again
the plan for today is to continue to be
up and out of bed
eat and drink and work as he is able and
i'd like to turn it over to dr jason
blaylock who's an infectious disease
specialist and the chief of medicine
here at walter reed to give some updates
on infection control
thank you
good afternoon everyone first of all i
just want to say
what an honor it's been to be part of
this medical team behind me
and to care for the president since the
president's arrival at
walter reed he's received medical
management that remains in line
with national clinical societal
guidelines
that's a red treatment of coven 19
infection i'll explain in addition
both myself and dr wes campbell have
worked very closely
with various laboratories in the area
state-of-the-art facilities to include
usamrid and rare on obtaining advanced
diagnostic testing
to really inform the white house medical
team of both the status of the president
as well as his ability to transmit virus
to others
also we have worked very closely with
to ensure that we are looking very
closely at
infection control prevention strategies
and the right posture
so that the president can safely return
to his residence
and with that i'm going to turn it over
to dr conley who uh
will answer any final question final
questions how about some questions how
about one
honestly i mentioned it saturday but i'd
like to reiterate myself
just how grateful the president and i
are to the men and women of walter reed
our colleagues at johns hopkins as well
as the many federal
private institutions that we've received
support from
has trump tested negative and so long as
everything continues on the track
that we're experiencing right now this
time
as the president already tweeted out is
to get him home later today
with that i'll take a couple questions
be discharged back to the white house
when
he was given steroids you've said that
he's still on those steroids those are
medicines as as you know that are
usually given to covet patients who are
on ventilators or
um with low oxygen so did you over treat
him and if he's still on that medication
how is it safe for him to return perfect
question
uh we send patients home with
medications all the time
uh he in fact yesterday afternoon he
probably met most of his
discharge requirements safely from the
hospital
and he's returning to a facility the
white house medical unit that's staffed
24 7
top-notch physicians nurses pas
logisticians and the unit here the team
here behind me is going to continue to
support us in that nature
infection control measures are you
taking and how was it safe for him to
drive around in a cloth mask yesterday
and how is it safe for him now to return
to the white house where there have been
so many cases correct how's any of this
safe
so the the the president
has been surrounded by medical
and security staff for days uh wearing
full ppe
um and yesterday uh the u.s secret
service agents
were in that same level of ppe for a
very short period of time
uh we've worked with our infectious
disease experts
uh to make some recommendations for how
to keep
um everything safe down at the white
house for the president
and those around him um we're looking at
where he's going to be able to
uh carry out his duties this is going to
implode you know office space
and i'll just say that it's in line with
everything we've been doing
upstairs for this for the last several
days
please on testing can you tell us when
he had his last
negative test was it thursday was it
wednesday when do you remember
when he had his last negative attack i
don't want to go backwards
not going to get uh is he negative now
i understand the contact racing uh as i
understand it is being done
wasn't about i'm not involved in that so
not not not the question or was this uh
something he pushed for
no so we try to get patients home and
out of the hospital
uh as quickly as is safe and reasonable
every day a patient stays in the
hospital unnecessarily is a risk to
themselves this guy's worse than berks
and atlas guys
it's being done upstairs here that we
can't safely
conduct down home that seven to 10 days
was a window that you'd be concerned
about
i don't think we're there yet so do you
have concerns about potential
worsening or reversal and what are your
plans for addressing that if it were to
happen
you're absolutely right and that's why
we all
remain cautiously optimistic um and on
guard
because we're in a bit of unchartered
territory when it comes to a patient
that received the therapies he has so
early in the course
right so we're looking to this weekend
if we can get through to monday
with him remaining the same or improving
better yet
then we will all take that final deep
sigh relief
but as i said 24 7 world-class medical
care
surrounding him down there we're not
going to miss anything
that we would caught up here where is he
physically going to be in the white
house
and how do what does that look like how
do you keep him safely quarantined i
wish i could go into that more
um but but i just can't one point
treatment so that has something to do
yesterday we talked about that
the several little temporary drops in
his oxygen and we had discussed that
uh as a team and elected uh to start it
early when in case that persisted or
worse
uh the potential risks and side effects
we all discussed
what day we looked at the data um and
decided that uh
we'd rather uh you know push ahead on it
and hold and risk uh you know the
opposite what about ct scans and chest
x-rays
what have you seen from his campaign uh
as far as travel goes
um we'll see oh my god they're going to
let him travel
status can you talk to about whether he
has any neurological symptoms
does he have any side effects from his
medications he seems out of control
no i think you've seen the videos uh and
now the tweets
shortly you know he's he's back
yeah or any inflammation
in his lungs at all so we we've done
routine standard imaging
um i'm just not uh at liberty to
you're discuss not telling us what those
lung scans showed just to be clear
so um there are hipaa rules and
regulations
that uh restrict me in uh trump can say
go tell him the truth sean
his safety and his and his own health uh
and
and
reasons sure how many times you said his
oxygen dropped several times can you
share how many times he was
on oxygen you said you checked with the
nursing staff
yesterday uh yeah yes yes so he he
uh two episodes like we talked about
yesterday uh
and both times that he received a little
bit of oxygen and recovered immediately
um no it wasn't required he wasn't short
of breath it was i wasn't looking ill
it was more of us trying to uh
anticipate needs and see how they
respond in both cases he didn't need it
um it came right off he didn't he didn't
need it didn't need the debt for
from very long at all didn't need oxygen
for multiple trips
are you at all concerned about your own
exposure and exposure to the medical
team
i i am concerned but as the cdc
says there are caveats for essential
employees
that as long as you continue to test
negative
you remain symptom-free and you keep a
mask
on when you're out and about which we do
uh inside the hospital 24 7
then then you can carry on your duties
yeah dodies
patient man has he been itchy to get out
of here
um the the president has uh been a
phenomenal patient
during his stay here amazing um and he's
he's been working
uh hand in glove with us and the team um
and today got to the point he's holding
court with the with those of us around
him the whole team
going over all the specifics the testing
the future
um way better than biden would be as a
patient be sure of that worth on what's
safe and what's reasonable
and he has never once pushed us to do
anything
that was beyond a safe and reasonable
practice that we all first
wanted against the president leaving
here and going back to the white house
today
no everybody says he's great to go
president said don't be afraid of kobe
do you agree with that
should we not be afraid i'm not going to
get into what the president says
his heart liver and kidney function was
normal or improving
um improving does that mean that there
were beautiful questions is it all
normal
like what's up with that yeah it's it's
all it's all normal right now
uh i would say he appeared to be a
little dehydrated
uh friday um
he got he was able to just drink and
recover from that
uh and yeah everything looks great
it's funny how much improvement trump's
done from a position where he was
supposedly fine all along right
yeah so the big first thing that we need
to do is that there is no evidence
of live virus still present that he
could
uh possibly transmit to others wow
that's what the infectious disease
experts
uh and some of our partners um military
civilian entities
doing some of these advanced diagnostics
how is that possible as soon
as we can identify that um routinely we
talk about
three days he's no longer contagious um
but we
we're checking him more routinely than
just waiting ten days
there's a possibility it's earlier than
that there's a chance that
it's it's a little bit later but we will
know as soon as possible
uh and then we will look at him
clinically how are you feeling how are
you doing
why have you decided not to use
administer hydroxychloroquine to the
president during his time here
uh we're i'm not going to go into all of
our debates about specific medicines and
therapies there are because dozens of
therapies that we were made aware of
that we considered that we discussed and
debated
and looked at you know the the existing
literature on
um and this is the regiment we chose
is he having some of the muscle aches
has he lost his sense of taste and smell
uh no we were just talking about that
what symptoms he has left
and uh he he's he
even the slight cough that he used to
have uh he doesn't really complain of at
all
he hasn't ever complained of uh muscle
aches um
and uh yeah he's he's up and back to him
old self
his old self one day just to be clear
how long will he still be actively
shedding the virus right um so this this
morning i believe there was even
an accounting by dr fauci referencing a
a
five day the first five days of illness
uh
that that you know people are most
likely to shed live viruses most likely
um there's a reason there's the ten days
is because most people by that time
after seven days
most folks don't have culturable live
virus they put it to 10 just to give
some extra space
it's never 100 you know between
everybody so
we'll see i can't i'm not going to put a
specific number
but we we look at that that window is
all i say
confined to his residence or will he be
allowed to return to the oval office
we're going to do uh whatever uh it
takes
for the president to safely conduct
business wherever it is he needs to do
uh within the residence in white house
is he on blood thinners and also has he
been using
have you been giving him tylenol advil
oh that came up i would like to say he
has not been on any fever reducing
medications for over 72 hours
for 72 hours that's a lie he's on
a a routine regimen of uh
you know covet therapy i'm not going to
go into specifics as to what he is and
is not on
why um
that the president had a mild cough from
nasal congestion and fatigue
on thursday now back to my colleague
john jacob's questionnaire the reason
knowing when the president's last
negative test is
important uh for that reason your words
what you said and also for the contact
tracing
uh but would you recommend it that given
those symptoms that he
uh go that the president go to that
bedminster fundraiser
it's not up to me necessarily uh the
president's schedule but i would say
that
uh it wasn't until after he returned
that we really sat down
then knowing uh the the news of the day
these that we really dove into
how are you feeling what's what's going
on those were the symptoms he was
experiencing on thursday
i'm not gonna get into uh it's
incoherent operations
when was his last negative test and what
was his viral load i know
everyone wants that uh yeah
i don't i don't have his viral load um
those
are some of the diagnostics that we're
sending out
uh that will really tell us when it's
safe for him to get back out and around
people
could you tell us anything on the last
negative test
uh that means yes precludes me from
going into too much that means yes
that you know i'm not liberty or doesn't
wish uh to be discussed
um at some future point maybe uh but
today
sorry i think that's it yeah thank you
guys thank you
wow what a completely worthless
presentation
uh what is continuing to stun me
is that they talk about how trump at
every six hours trump's doing better and
better
and yet at no point was he supposedly
doing poorly it's almost like he's
coming out
strong he came in at a hundred percent
and he's leaving at 110
because he's been improving since he
came in
these people are worthless but they're
also some of the worst most
transparent liars that you can imagine
it is unbelievable
completely unbelievable let me stick
around for a bit
and just see some of the super chats and
and messages from people
i invite you uh support by the way
trump's leaving at 6 30 p.m i think
i would commit to a second stream if we
if we got to 25
members otherwise i'm going to go and
golf at bedminster
but other i would commit to another
stream later when trump leaves
uh maybe we we are i'm half kidding of
course by the way
but partially uh telling the truth let's
get to some of the super chats that are
coming in from people
uh alta miradarable says doctors are
bound by patient doctor secrecy they're
only relaying the white house narrative
exactly
he's there telling us what trump said to
say that's it
or you know people around trump uh chris
sem says i'm not a doctor but i play one
on tv
this doctor is less trustworthy than dr
oz will he receive a fresh pack of baby
diapers they keep changing the info
maybe the infected blotus is being
discharged home on hospice care i i
don't think so i don't think so
how can an osteopath be the chief white
house doctor it is weird i mean listen i
i'm not like all about attacking
um attacking uh osteopaths they do as
far as i know the same residencies as
mds
but you would imagine that the white
house doctor would would would be an md
i mean
it is a it's a fair it's a fair point
thanks to simp daddy kane for the twitch
sub
as well as flash ram and oak 84 also big
thank you to ansel
74 and egalitarian beggar
the weebs has gifted a subscription big
puffy cake
is in the action film bro nick and so
many great people
we've got sean sawake is new member
number
12 today and mary mccormack
is new member number 13. other super
chats
michelle asks whether everyone in the
white house will wear ppe
who knows i mean really who knows
pedro asks has he had two consecutive
negative covet tests
oh he would obviously be positive now
right i mean there's no chance now
i don't even think they're asserting
trump would be negative now
i think the argument they're making is
he's on the edge
of being contagious or or something like
that i'm guessing that that's
the argument they're making maria says
hey david you're the voice
of reason in these crazy times keep up
the great work do you think trump will
be able to turn this in his favor i
don't know if he will but he's going to
try
satu gustafson says do you still still
believe it's definitely not a stunt
i'm quite convinced now he never had cob
fefi when he talked about medication
sent from god
listen i think he had it i think he had
it but
um and let's be honest unless they're
now faking that
everybody has it it would almost be
weird like
if if bill stephen has it and magananny
has it
and ronna mcdann you know if all these
people have unless they're
all lying about having it it's it's
starting to be hard to believe that
trump wouldn't have it to be perfectly
frank
that's uh that that's sort of where my
thought is right now
michael says good thing the coronavirus
never came to the united states just
like kaylee mckenna
said we really dodged a bullet i know
right i know
eric's spawner has subscribed on twitch
so has peggy sent claire
oh people are asking about my uh
coronavirus test
i was negative negative negative it was
days ago
i mean certainly it could have been a
false negative i had what i can only
describe as sort of some
um allergy like symptoms
and uh my doctor said
let's just get a covid test to rule it
out because if you were contagious
if you had coveton were contagious and
were bringing you to get allergy tests
and stuff like that
that would be bad so i went in it was a
much
i drove in it was a much thinner swab i
was pleased when they took the swab or
schwab as some would call it out
i was expecting the big boy with the
thick almost like a q-tip
end this was very very thin
and at first when it went in it was
really only in my nostril and i
at that point for about half a second i
thought oh my god
this schwab is nothing but that was only
an alignment
then it went in about two more inches
and at that point i definitely
you know had a i experienced a reaction
but it was literally five seconds five
seconds
and um you know i guess if i wanted to
be
extra careful i could go and get another
one but the truth is i don't have
coronavirus symptoms i seem to just be
having allergies so now we will move on
to allergy testing my friends very very
important to do
a thanks to daniel busha as well as
peter fritzen who are new members 14
and 15 today at joinpackman.com
also liam hendricks is new member number
16
at joinpakman.com uh and we will
continue to monitor
uh you know i mean even though we didn't
get 25 members i i'll probably just
stream again
when donald trump is going to be leaving
walter reed assuming that
we will have video of it the only thing
i think i would ask you guys
is please ping me via my website contact
form
if indeed you start seeing video of
trump leaves walter reed live if there
are streams i can pick
up let me know i'm going to be working
on tomorrow's show for the next couple
of hours
let me know and i'll be back for an
extremely powerful
second live stream of the day um
a little bit later and no trump's not
scheduled to leave office i know some of
some people in the twitch chat got their
uh got got their hopes up
trump scheduled to leave the hospital
scheduled to leave the hospital
and um let me know and i will be back
in a couple of hours i'll be doing uh
some
other work uh maybe maybe go to the
grocery store maybe do a couple push-ups
or that type of thing
and we will potentially be back for
trump helicoptering off back to the
white house a little bit later